foreign
[Music]
so here I have two devices
and I will transfer one dollar from this
device to this device instantaneously
into the amount
and scent
I'm singing the transaction now
[Music]
and there it is
what you've just witnessed is what looks
like a standard financial transaction
money was transferred electronically
from one account to another
but while it appears like an ordinary
bank transfer it may perhaps be the most
revolutionary technology you're likely
to see in your lifetime
this technology is called Bitcoin
money makes possible the exchange of
many different goods and services among
many different people
wherever we go we see money being used
as a medium of Exchange
[Applause]
money is at the core of our existence
every day we transact with one another
currently almost all of our daily
transactions involve a third party
a bank credit card company or remittance
provider and ultimately it's these
institutions that carry out the
transaction on our behalf
this is until the invention of Bitcoin
Bitcoin is truly one of the most
important inventions ever in the history
of humankind that's how big of an impact
it's going to have on our lives
and it sounds really difficult and
complicated and hard to understand
hearing about it if you'd only heard
about email it would sound difficult and
complicated and hard to use Bitcoin is
literally easier to use than email
[Music]
so what exactly is Bitcoin
well for starters Bitcoin isn't actually
a coin
Bitcoin is a new form of money
a currency that lives solely on the
internet one that some have even called
Magic internet money
[Music]
I think part of the confusion is that
Bitcoin is actually two different things
it's both a currency and a payment
Network
and we've never had one thing that's
both of those at the same time so the
dollar is a currency but it's not a
payment Network PayPal and Visa or
payment networks but they're not
currencies Bitcoin just both of those
things at the same time but it has this
other property and that other property
is that it can instantly be teleported
anywhere in the world just like that
almost for free and there's nothing that
anybody can do to block these
teleportations there's nothing anybody
can do to intercept these teleportations
and if you're careful about how you use
Bitcoin you can do these teleportations
anonymously so with Bitcoin with a push
of a button you can pay anyone anywhere
in the world or receive payment from
anyone anywhere in the world
[Music]
in the aftermath of the global financial
crisis an author using the pseudonym
Satoshi Nakamoto posted a nine-page
document onto an online forum
the document titled Bitcoin a
peer-to-peer electronic cash system
would soon become the building block for
what is today the first fully working
concept of decentralized money
these are the daily candles of Bitcoin
just in the backdrop but I want to talk
about these are trend lines you've seen
on my other presentations even earlier
today
I started out working at Bear Stearns
back in 2007 so about a year and a half
or so before the financial crisis really
started to hit and after bear Stearns I
joined JP Morgan where I became a VP and
that was my last job all of these jobs
were either Midtown or downtown
Manhattan
vase is a Wall Street veteran a former
VP at JP Morgan he now spends his time
studying and educating audiences about
Bitcoin
Bitcoin is generally difficult to
explain uh you want to try and break it
down as simple as you can so the
simplest way is is basically it's a it's
like a message it's a digital message
that you're passing and normally we're
all used to computers we're all sending
emails we're all sending pictures but
you're always sending a copy anytime you
hit the send button in a computer
you always retain a copy always retain
the original and when it comes to
financial transactions you hit the send
button and you have an intermediary the
bank that is moving money from one
account to another
and this is the problem that Bitcoin
solved it was able to take something
digital and when you hit the send button
you're not actually sending a copy
you're actually sending
um a digital object
at its core Bitcoin is basically a new
monetary system however Bitcoin is
unlike any other system we've seen in
the past because it isn't centralized in
one place
this decentralized nature of the Bitcoin
platform is one of the things that make
it so unique and world-changing
[Music]
we're all familiar with PayPal or Visa
or Bank of whatever
all of these traditional services that
we're used to
control who's allowed to have an account
who can send money from who from what
countries users can send money to other
countries users with Bitcoin there is no
entity that's controlling any of that
there's just this software protocol that
anyone can write software to interact
with and then anyone can install that
software on their phone or on their
computer and once they have the software
installed they can now interact with
anyone else anywhere in the entire world
that's also using the Bitcoin software
this software that runs the Bitcoin
protocol is commonly called a wallet a
digital purse which stores and allows
the holder to move Bitcoins from one
wallet to another
the Bitcoin protocol is open source
meaning that the programming code is
freely available to add to and
redistribute
in this way similar to anyone being able
to add a new website to the World Wide
Web programmers are able to add new
products to the Bitcoin Network
foreign
we have Jason for whom this is very late
evening because he is in Australia and
we're about to do Jason's first Bitcoin
transaction over Skype as our medium so
everyone can see how quick and easy it
is on my end
my end hit ascend
and uh Jason is going to hit request
so when he hits request a QR code should
have displayed in the middle of your
screen
and he's gonna put it up to the camera
of Skype so I can scan it with the
camera in my cell phone all right I see
the QR code my phone is trying to scan
it and there it is I scanned it so I
feel kind of generous let's send Jason
five dollars
so I have just sent Jason five dollars
in Bitcoin uh and let me know when it's
registering on your end that you have
five dollars worth of bitcoin
and there it is okay so that took about
10 to 15 seconds
[Music]
Bitcoin enables users to send and
receive money instantly without the
involvement of a third party
this digital breakthrough allows the
user to effectively become their own
bank
this is a complex idea to handle but the
possibilities of this new bankless
currency are enormous
foreign
with the exception of actually handing
physical cash to you generally we have
to rely on third parties for lots of
different payments be it credit cards or
wire transfers internationally or even
sort of keeping cash under your bed
storing large amounts of cash we use
Banks and what Bitcoin does is allow us
to do all of those things without any
third parties so in that sense we can be
our own bank we can be our own payment
system we can be our own International
wire system we can be our own remittance
system we can do all of these things
without relying on any other third
parties that's what Bitcoin allows us to
do
[Music]
before Bitcoin all these companies like
PayPal and decent Bank of America and
you know any business they had a ledger
that kept track of all their account
balances so PayPal has a ledger that
keeps track of exactly who how much
money you need to PayPal account and
that ledger is stored on PayPal servers
and PayPal status Center somewhere
and before the invention of Bitcoin
people thought that it was impossible
all the mathematicians and computer
scientists thought that it was
impossible to have consensus on a
distributed Ledger like this but what
Bitcoin did is it came along and figured
out how to keep track of this Ledger
that keeps track of who has what
Bitcoins but instead of that ledger
being on one data center it's on
everybody's computer across the entire
planet that's running the Bitcoin
Network and putting my laptop right here
I have a full copy of the entire Bitcoin
uh Ledger
[Music]
this public Ledger known as the
blockchain is perhaps what could make
Bitcoin a financial game changer
Bitcoin is what is known as a
cryptocurrency meaning that it's a
digital currency in which encryption is
used to regulate the creation of new
units and verify the transfer of funds
new Bitcoins come into existence through
a process called mining a minor is a
person or entity who runs a very
powerful computer in an effort to solve
a complex mathematical puzzle known as a
block miners around the world compete to
solve or close a block and are rewarded
with newly generated Bitcoins if they're
successful
all transactions that travel through the
Bitcoin Network are pieces of this
complex mathematical puzzle so when a
miner solves a puzzle they're actually
verifying the Integrity of each and
every transaction
this is one giant abandoned recycling
plant we've got incinerators over there
those two big silos
right around this wall we have a
megawatt worth of solar panels
a lot
um
that's about as much as what we consume
so we're going to be able to offset our
electrical costs completely
this is a work in progress but a Bitcoin
mine is a group of computers that
contribute its processing power to
facility Bitcoin transfers and security
of the network yeah it is one big
supercomputer and all of these
individual computers
are kind of throwing guesses at this
mathematical problem
it's a it's a very difficult problem it
takes lots and lots of computers to
guess it once that guess is
correct
that is sent to all the rest of the
computers and with that answer they
record all the transactions that have
been done up to that point it's a very
secure system for facilitating transfers
recording transfers and making sure that
no kind of shady work has been done
because there's some methods in in
financial transactions where you could
double spend
and this whole blockchain thing is is
one great method of make sure that
doesn't happen
I say if Alice wants to send Bob an
email
what would happen under the the hood is
that along the path of the email across
the network
her email gets copied
in many places of the network and
eventually the final copy will be
related to Bob
that's how email works that's how
digital transfers work and that's how it
should work for for the majority of
digital transfers
that's that's well and good however in
the case of money that would be
disastrous if if that were to be the way
that money was transferred digitally
um you don't want copies of the same
dollar bill to be to exist on the
network that would ruin the scarcity uh
uh premise of money
and so this was the problem that Satoshi
Nakamoto tackled with the creation of
Bitcoin and so what happens with Bitcoin
on the bitcoin's blockchain is that when
Alice wants to send one Bitcoin to Bob
she creates a transaction and that
transaction gets copied across the
entire network however this is different
than say a single email because that
transaction has embedded in it
instructions to the rest of the network
that says from here on out control over
this Bitcoin is now conferred to Bob
okay and the rest of the network Honors
that
one time I realized that wow Bitcoin is
really difficult for people to
understand is I spent the whole evening
explaining Bitcoin to a friend of mine
and then I got home that night and she
posted on my Facebook page and she goes
yeah I was thinking more about Bitcoins
and you were explaining Bitcoin mining
and does that mean that Bitcoins are
originally Underground
I realized that
bitcoin's a difficult concept for for
people to understand and especially
Bitcoin mining as well because Bitcoins
are not originally Underground
[Music]
for new users Bitcoin can be a difficult
concept to understand
Bitcoins aren't physical and they
certainly aren't Underground
however there are some interesting
similarities between Bitcoin and a
precious metal that is found underground
gold gold has been money and a store of
value for thousands of years
today gold is mined all over the world
the amount of gold that can be extracted
from the ground decreases over the life
of a mine until eventually the miners
exhausted of all of its gold
Bitcoins are also mined in a similar
fashion
the Bitcoin algorithm is programmed so
that the reward for mining new Bitcoins
is halved every four years until the
year 2140 when all Bitcoins will have
been deemed to have been mined
perhaps the mysterious Creator behind
Bitcoin was trying to mimic the
attributes of gold almost as if to
create a digital gold coin which could
be divided and then sent instantly
around the world
I try to explain it in some really
simple way like uh miners Bitcoin are in
miners they receive the reward just
because they maintain the security of
Bitcoin mathematically it means that you
need to solve
quite difficult problems is that just
guessing process you have to make
millions and millions millions of
guesses and if you're right and you are
able to close all these transactions
inside of one block you're successful
and you receive 12.5 Bitcoins as minor
originally this reward was 50 Bitcoins
every four years these
this reward for miners is two times less
so real world we will be decreasing over
the time
the creator of Bitcoin whoever he is
those are really really really smart guy
and uh he obviously liked math a lot and
he sat down and did some calculations
and thought to himself if everybody in
the entire world were to start using
Bitcoin
how many Bitcoins would we need in order
for that to be able to accommodate
everybody using Bitcoin for this and uh
each Bitcoin can be divided down to 100
millionth of a Bitcoin and if everybody
in the entire world were to start using
Bitcoin as their money the smallest unit
of a Bitcoin which is called the Satoshi
it's 100 millionth of a Bitcoin would
still be worth less than one US penny if
the entire world were to start using
Bitcoin
so who is this Satoshi Nakamoto
two years after publishing the white
paper for the peer-to-peer electronic
cash system this mysterious figure
vanished never to be heard from again
the only Clues to his or her identity
can be found in the white paper
some speculate he or she is of British
origin due to the writings containing
some British slang others believe that
rather than being one person Satoshi was
a group of hackers working in concert to
create a new monetary system which would
decentralize money as we know it
I think he was a clever guy he was not a
normal gig he had
good knowledge of decentralized
technology or
decentralization
he had good knowledge Financial system
and he was
quite good color but the call of Bitcoin
is not definitely the best one so it's
definitely possible to to write better
code there is also conspiration theory
if Bitcoin code was written by one guy
or many different guys hard to say
anyway I especially appreciate that it's
first fully working concept of
personalized money
it's very interesting like who Satoshi
is there's lots of speculation
especially among like the very early
people in Bitcoin
but what difference does it make whether
we know who created bitcoin uh
I don't know I don't know that it makes
any difference there's lots of stuff
that we use that we don't know who
created it and yet it gives us a lot of
advantages in our day-to-day activities
I have no idea who Satoshi is um we know
very little about Satoshi and so he
could be at an event um he could be
someone we know it could be someone I've
spoken to he could be a friend of mine
for all I know I don't know who it is I
don't know if we'll ever know but it's a
fun game am I Satoshi
[Music]
I don't think I'll answer that one
regardless of the true identity of
Satoshi what he or she has invented
could have profound effects on how our
world evolves into the future
country
because Bitcoin enables the user to act
as their own bank in essence it frees
the user from the traditional
Gatekeepers to their wealth
is
[Music]
we all use keys in our daily lives Keys
allow us to access and control our
valued possessions they also protect our
valuables from being stolen
take your car as an example holding the
keys to your car allows you access to it
whenever you wish but suppose you've had
a few too many to drink and your loyal
friend confiscates your keys from you
the car may still be yours but now you
no longer control it
and must hail a ride home the same can
be said of our finances although you may
have the debit card and password to your
bank account the funds aren't directly
in your possession every time you make a
withdrawal or transfer from your bank
account the bank is actually acting on
your behalf and moving the funds for you
this is where Bitcoin is fundamentally
different
Bitcoin enables an individual to hold
the private keys of their own wealth so
with pretty much every asset that we
have out there
uh we don't directly hold the Dominion
or control over that asset for example
the Royal Bank of Scotland they had 700
000 accounts ATMs just went down for the
weekend nobody could access the ATMs
couldn't get money out
you have a credit card or a debit card
and it gets turned off because of
suspected fraud or you did a charge in a
unusual location well guess what the
credit card company holds those private
keys they get to make the choice not you
Bitcoin is very very different in this
regard it is built on public private key
encryption
and what that means is that you send
Bitcoins to the public key
and then in order to send the Bitcoins
you have to be able to sign with the
private key where the Bitcoins currently
reside
and that literally is a number that
private key is a number Bitcoin nobody
gets to turn it off if you have the
private key you get to access it and use
it
with your Bitcoin wallets that there's
Associated what are called private Keys
okay and these are literally what they
sound like they're private keys that can
open and unlock your access to your
funds but let's be clear if you lose any
of your private Keys you lose access to
your funds simple as that
[Music]
so we just bought some Bitcoins out of a
local Bitcoin ATM and so what actually
comes out is what we call a cold wallet
it's a little piece of paper with two
squares on it or two things that look
like Roche ink watch tests and a bunch
of alphanumerics underneath each now the
top is the public key which is what
people would use to send Bitcoins to
this address and the bottom one is the
private key which is what you would use
to scan in order to retrieve Bitcoins
from this address now it's very
important to note that that private key
is something that you really shouldn't
be showing around everywhere because
whoever scans this first will be able to
take the Bitcoins off this address also
if you were to happen to lose this piece
of paper then you've actually
essentially lost your Bitcoins because
nobody else has a copy of this private
key right now there actually is some
Bitcoins on this address so if you're
seeing this for the first time you may
be able to scan this off yourself and
take the Bitcoins for yourself
thank you
[Music]
so here is a Satori coin
there is a value of
0.001 Bitcoin inside
in today's
exchange rate
that would mean about 45 cents
so it's very minimal uh amount but it is
true Bitcoin inside
now how to redeem the value out of this
token
one would have to peel off the Hologram
sticker
in the back
here we go
and then
our QR code would be exposed and this QR
code is the private key information
which is essentially like a password
and with this private key
and only with this private key
one can redeem you can import
that value to your Bitcoin wallet
anything else physical has a very strong
sense of Authority or authenticity and
to make the barrier to entry to bitcoin
as low as possible I think everyone
working on their project felt it was
really important that someone could have
a part of Bitcoin that they can hold in
their hands that's portable and doesn't
cost very much to get started it's kind
of a low commitment object
because Bitcoin is built on public
private key encryption the entire
workflow for sending payments
particularly online is fundamentally
different from that of credit cards
credit cards were never built to be used
on the internet in the first place I
mean the credit cards were made there
was no internet
so a pool system is that you've given
the authorization to the merchant or the
credit card issue to pull from your bank
account
whenever it is that they feel that they
have the right to do so with a credit
card whenever you want to initiate a
transaction you are effectively giving
the keys to the merchant right and you
give your keys to every Merchant you you
deal with
um so every time you make a transaction
for example online or so you're taking a
risk because you're entrusting the
merchant with these this very personal
information which they could then take
to initiate transactions as well if they
wanted to
whereas Bitcoin it's a completely
different model where the control
uh is more weighted towards the the
consumer the consumer then pushes their
their funds to you
um and then
um if you're doing an internet service
right you could broadcast a Bitcoin
address and anyone in the world could
send Bitcoin to you if you were a band a
musical band
and you're you're performing on the
concert
and your concert was being broadcast uh
you know around the world if you put up
on the stage a a
sign that had a Bitcoin address well you
could be funded by anyone who's watching
that broadcast anytime they watched it
from that point onward
my name is San Shiro Fujimoto and I
place the saxophone and the other
instruments I compose and perform and
make CDs and I make my living by being a
musician
today's a small live show I did without
no admission fee and if you appreciate
my music then you can tip me
by tipping you don't know how much it
might get zero or if your performance is
great you might get more than you think
so
that makes me play better
[Music]
[Applause]
direct interaction is more more about
the art itself and if you tip someone in
the street you don't tip big money you
tip like
10 cents quarters and small money but to
send the small money on the internet
cost more than what you're supposed to
tip so Bitcoin is much better way to tip
someone in the internet
coin payments are a push system meaning
that the funds are pushed from sender to
receiver
this makes for a faster and cheaper
system than traditional pool systems
like credit card transactions
this in turn also means that Bitcoin
transactions are final and cannot be
reversed
credit cards actually has about a six
month settlement type even though the
transaction looks like it went through
the person can then call back and say
this was a fraudulent transaction and
then the credit card will take that
money away from the merchant in some
cases in some cases the credit card will
eat the cost and that's a chargeback now
we pay for this this is the three
percent fee Merchants usually pay this
three percent in order to accept credit
cards so Bitcoin transactions don't have
chargebacks I think of it as a good
thing as much as people like to say how
how great it is to dispute things it
very very rarely happens
almost never do you order something from
a legitimate company
and you were not satisfied and then the
company did not solve your problem most
of the time this situation happens is
when your credit card is actually stolen
and your credit card is can always be
stolen everyone's credit card is all
over the Internet is just luck or bad
luck if your credit card happens to be
used in a fraudulent transaction
we have some businesses accepting
Bitcoin mostly restaurants for example
we have some restaurants here set up in
Acapulco for merchants when they accept
Bitcoin is for them to have another
option an Innovative option and for them
they have they have a lot of advantages
we don't charge what the credit card
fees charge every time they Slide the
the card three four five even ten
percent depending on the credit card we
don't charge anything we don't have a
minimum fee you can pay
uh 10 pesos 50 pesos we don't have a
minimum
with Bitcoin payments lowering the cost
of doing business and eliminating the
possibility of fraudulent transactions
companies ranging from Mom and Pop
stores to multinational corporations
have started to embrace this new way to
transfer value
medical school and this is
our business here it's 1997 to 1999.
foreign
the first large publicly traded company
to accept Bitcoin is Overstock
and they now ship goods to over 200
countries last I checked Amazon only
ships to about 50 60 countries so
they're seeding entire markets with
entire populations in the billions not
even fighting for that market share
additionally if Amazon accepted Bitcoin
there would be no fraud there would be
no charge backs so it would lower their
costs it would greatly increase Amazon's
profit margins to accept Bitcoin
foreign
allows Merchants to accept payments for
their products and services seamlessly
and although it's becoming a great tool
for merchants to offer their products to
previously untapped markets it's the
people in these developing countries who
will benefit the most
[Music]
Bitcoin is the easiest safest fastest
best option for people that don't have
bank accounts or that don't have IDs or
they don't have anything but a
smartphone and there's lots and lots of
people in the world that that's the
position that they're in and Bitcoin is
this fantastic solution and an
opportunity for them to participate in
the world's economy without having to
deal with banks and having to jump
through all these hoops they just simply
install an app and now they're part of
the world's economy
something like
33 percent of the credit card
transactions Coming Out of Africa are
fraudulent so nobody wants to take
business from Africa it's just too risky
with Bitcoin you know the funds are good
so as a merchant yeah pay with Bitcoin
also anything you want you know that's
legal to Africa then they're able to
start having property rights
and property rights is really what's
going to help lift them up out of
poverty
so Bitcoin does get into the the snitch
of the underserved people in the banking
industry
um so a lot of third world countries
they may not have access to bank
accounts they might not even have IDs to
open a bank account but if they have
cell phones and if they have access to
the internet they can now have the
equivalent of a bank in their cell phone
according to the latest World Bank
figures there are approximately 2
billion unbanked people throughout the
developing world the adoption and use of
Bitcoin in these countries could
transform this human rights issue and
allow the unbanked population of the
world to participate in the global
economy
for the first time in the entire history
of the world anyone can now send or
receive any amount of money with anyone
else anywhere instantly basically for
free and it's impossible for anyone
including governments to stop them from
doing that
and as much as I love gold gold gold
can't do that right
think about that anybody in this room
you cannot send and receive any amount
of money with anyone anywhere in the
world right now and there's nothing that
anybody can do to stop that that was not
possible before the invention of Bitcoin
and that is a fundamentally
world-changing technology for every
single human being on the planet
Wikileaks I was able to find funding
through Bitcoin
and this was in the midst of a financial
blockade that Wikileaks was facing at
the time the U.S had ordered the uh
Visa I think it was MasterCard as well I
think of America to blockade any
donations to WikiLeaks
say what you will about Wiki you know
Wikileaks not necessarily that I can
donate everything that they do but I do
think it is very important
for freedom in the world for people to
have
uncensorable ability to to donate money
to whatever political causes that they
want to and so I thought that was
extremely powerful for a week at least
to be able to defy the US in that sense
because Bitcoin puts the private keys of
wealth in the hands of the user it can
be used to support activist causes
but Bitcoin can also be used for a night
out on a town
[Music]
my name is Ken shishido I am core
organizer for Tokyo Bitcoin Meetup group
we have this uh special event tonight
having a burlesque dancers receiving
Bitcoin tips
the reason why I do this is that
sometimes we want to make our Meetup
interesting instead of you know talking
about really really technical stuff or
political stuff so this is one of the
events we want to make a really fun and
see what can be done using Bitcoin
[Music]
currently
if you're living in in most countries
buying things is not a problem you have
credit cards you can still use cash and
to me that is not the true use of
Bitcoin the true use of Bitcoin is to
give you Financial privacy which I find
extremely important
during the global financial crisis as
cracks in the financial system spread
institutions once thought to be
Invincible were shown to be vulnerable
as we now know governments around the
world were forced to bail out financial
institutions
a bailout is When government takes
taxpayer money and gives it to an
irresponsible financial institution to
bail out their mistakes
a bailin is different in that laws are
written which permit financial
institutions to take funds directly from
customer accounts to shore up their
losses
such a thing occurred in Cyprus in 2013.
when I started learning about Bitcoin
back in 2013 especially during the
Cyprus event when Banks were shut down
and money was confiscated from people I
remember telling my co-workers some of
the phds the quants this is really bad
this is actually gonna probably start
happening in many other Western
countries and they were all laughing at
me saying no it's just Cyprus it'll
never happen here
and that's when I knew is someone must
have come up with a way to get around
this problem
a depositor deposits dollars or euros
into the bank titled to the dollars or
Euros transfers to the bank and those
depositors become unsecured creditors of
the bank if the banks screw up for
whatever reason there's now been
legislation passed in many of the
countries where they can be bailed in
meaning that their deposits can be
turned into shares of the bank
Jeff Berwick is an entrepreneur
Financial commentator and podcast host
having founded stockhouse.com Canada's
largest financial news website Jeff's
analysis writings and videos have been
viewed by millions of people around the
world
it's difficult to say exactly what's
going to happen in the future but it's
definitely going to keep happening I
said after Cyprus is going to happen in
Greece and then they shut down the banks
in Greece for months and of interest to
people who live in Europe is on January
1st of this year they passed a European
Bank bail in legislation so that that
should be a huge wake-up call to people
that they're doing that so in Cyprus
they didn't actually pass it before so
in Cyprus they closed the banks then
they came up with some legislation and
said the banks could just take their
customers money to keep afloat so they
didn't even have that legislation and
they did that in Cyprus now they already
have it in place so they know what's
coming
when I see Bitcoin as a way to
protect and hide your assets and we're
not saying this is bad I'm not saying
that only criminals hide their assets no
people that have worked hard and they've
paid taxes and they've done everything
and like what happened in the Greece and
Cyprus where money in bank accounts was
just confiscated so if the next time the
banking system gets in trouble it could
be users accounts that are rated to help
fund the banking system we're talking
people with significant money
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
but it's legal money they've worked hard
for it
some economists believe that the global
financial crisis of the last decade was
just a precursor to a much larger
calamity
if this is the case how will governments
react in response to the next failure of
our financial system
unlike the current banking system
Bitcoin allows individuals to hold the
private keys to their wealth
however this also comes with the added
responsibility of securing the Bitcoins
with Bitcoin you're in 100 complete
control of your own money but that also
means you're a 100 responsible for what
happens to your own money so it's your
job to make sure that you keep your
Bitcoin safe people are used to things
like credit cards and bank accounts and
PayPal and if your credit card gets
stolen you just call the credit card
company and they cancel it and that's
the end of it if your Bitcoins get
stolen there's nobody that you can call
to ask to for ask for help but uh the
other side of the coin there's there's
nobody that you have to call to ask for
permission to use your Bitcoins however
you want so it cuts both ways
Mount Cox the tokyo-based Bitcoin
exchange has filed for bankruptcy
protection the announcement comes days
after the exchange announced that as
much as 450 million dollars of the
virtual currency had gone missing CEO
Mark Capelli's apologized and bowed
deeply on Japanese television it remains
unclear if the missing Bitcoins were
stolen voided by technological flaws or
both
so actually this is the the old Mount
gox building Mount Cox was the biggest
Bitcoin exchange that ever existed I
think at some point they were doing over
a hundred million dollars a day worth of
volume and they collapsed in a quite a
spectacular fashion in 2014.
I think the size of the losses mounted
to over 450 million dollars they claim
to have lost 850
000 Bitcoins of which 200 000 were found
afterwards in some old wallet people
were putting money in and essentially
giving them their Bitcoins giving them
the control of their private keys and
and the irony is that exact
centralization risk is what Bitcoin is
supposed to
free us from and mount gox just took all
of the decentralized nature of Bitcoin
and put into one company with a lot of
people's money and then on top of that
puts a control of that company's
finances under one person who has the
keys to the kingdom
so we've probably seen over the last two
or three years I Would by my count
probably somewhere between half a dozen
um to upwards of 10 different
major hacks of companies that are
involved in Bitcoin uh and one thing you
have to understand is that Bitcoin is
fundamentally different from uh securian
asset that's you know that's helped
within the regular Financial space
with Bitcoin if you ever get access to
the private key of Tucson's wallet you
can initiate a transaction
outside of the infrastructure of that
company without their knowledge that's
unlike anything that exists currently in
the financial space where if you want to
take money out of the
uh you know that Target you have to have
infiltrated their their infrastructure
I think it's part of the mentality where
people are trained not to trust
themselves with their own money and so
everybody puts their money in bank for
safekeeping and so that that sort of
mentality where you put your money in in
some pooled company whose sole purpose
is to safeguard it
that is a really hard stigma to break
the change
um and I think this is the thing that's
the most challenging about Bitcoin is
that
it challenges people to question that
stigma
um it challenges people to take control
of your own money and value and to
safeguard it yourself
as we know at this time Bitcoin is quite
secure if you have more than a half of
Bitcoin natural cover you can take a
control of the Bitcoin network but
technically this is really hard when we
consider the current bitcoin power it's
almost impossible so from this point a
few Bitcoin is much secure than the the
biggest and most secure portals of some
biggest banks in the world
the problem is that many people do not
trust Bitcoin just because there were a
lot of news about hacking some Bitcoin
portals and some big change services and
so on the problem is that uh like
all services uh based on Bitcoins is not
a Bitcoin you know itself so you can you
cannot associate or you cannot associate
this security of
Bitcoin Based Services with the the
Bitcoin itself
the collapse of the mount gogs Bitcoin
exchange in 2014 caused much confusion
and skepticism about the security of
Bitcoin
however years after the collapse of the
one's largest Bitcoin exchange Bitcoin
is now on the radar of many institutions
within the financial industry
the big question that the conversation
you you would you hear it is that the
question was whether
blockchain technology would impact the
financial industry
and now if you go to the trade shows and
you listen to uh the media the question
is not whether the question is how
blockchain technology will will impact
and transform the financial industry
it's now a foregone conclusion that
blockchain technology will impact the
financial industry in a major way
so so that's where we are now but we
weren't always there uh if you look just
three years ago two years ago
um the attitude was that Bitcoin was
almost a laughable concept and it was a
non-sustainable system and it couldn't
be applied in the financial space
in Japan the virtual currency law has
passed in the low house and hopefully
actually it will pass in the upper house
as well in the very near future that
means actually government recognizes the
existence of the virtual currency
and I'm trying to actually set some
regressions
and try to actually support the business
[Music]
uh this Bitcoin why it looks uh great
you know
it's a nice piece of collection you know
it's better than a Yen or a penny
some of the areas where Bitcoin has been
most popular so far as China which has
quite a high level of capital controls
other countries like China Argentina
Iran this is where bitcoin's really
caught on to a lot of people because you
just simply it's not easy to transfer
money in or out of the country without
going through regulatory problems or
having to know someone in the government
and things like that so definitely that
is a huge boost to bitcoin
the advantages of Bitcoin continue to
increase its popularity around the world
sometimes in the most unlikely of places
my name is David Hyatt and I operate the
Phoenix Rising Cafe in nimbin
this is where our Bitcoin machine is
located right next to the traditional
ATM machine so the customers have a
choice of using either
I saw that the current banking system
was rather restrictive and the
independence of people running their own
banking systems really appealed to me
and the fact also that it was digital
and we're living in a digital age I just
knew that it was something that would
have to get traction over time
Bitcoin is definitely the largest
innovation in monetary science since
Isaac Newton's gold standard going to
completely revolutionize how all of our
assets are held so it's going to disrupt
a law it's going to disrupt accounting
going to disrupt our finance industry
gonna disrupt so much
it will also
rapidly decentralize
the
capital
it's no longer
will millions of people
accumulate all of their Capital into one
big pile that then gets allocated by a
senior vice president of Merrill Lynch
or Bank of America it'll be millions of
people that you have to go and entice
out of their Capital go fight a war in
Afghanistan or Iraq once you
decentralize all those private Keys it
becomes much more difficult to get
people to pay for a lot of these goods
and services that they otherwise
wouldn't necessarily pay for
I'll just scan it and now I have your
Bitcoin address in my wallet right here
and I'll go ahead and enter one dollar
and we'll hit send mine sending the
transaction
[Music]
sent and if you there you go you heard
the noise
before Bitcoin I was basically retired I
was just hanging out enjoying my life
practicing Jiu Jitsu every day and it
was really fun but wasn't really going
to make the world that much of a better
place if at all
um
and then I discovered Bitcoin and I
looked around the world and I saw these
wars being fought in central banks
debased in the currency and basically
preventing the world from being as good
of a place as it potentially could be
and I saw Bitcoin and I saw this as a
tool to strip away all of their power to
do that most people aren't interested in
paying to kill people they've never met
in other countries
um most people are willing to pay for
roads and schools and hospitals so if
the governments say we need money for
roads and schools and hospitals I think
people would probably give them a good
chunk of that if governments say we need
money to go kill people in other
countries that you've never been to in
your entire life and you're probably
never going to go to in your entire life
people are going to say no I don't want
to pay for that but with if you're using
bank accounts and dollars and Euros
governments can seize all the money out
of your bank account at any time they
can print as many new dollars or Euros
as they want to pay for these things at
any time if the world's using Bitcoin it
takes away those tools from government
and I think that makes the world a much
much better place
first time in history Bitcoin now
provides the entire world with a
completely decentralized payment system
one where each individual holds the
ownership and control of their own
Financial wealth
one where all users can transfer value
and interact freely amongst each other
instantly
what could the future of our world look
like with such a revolutionary tool
the possibilities could be truly magical
[Music]
Bitcoin is Magic internet money
Bitcoin allows you to send and receive
money with anyone anywhere in the world
just like magic there's
[Music]
I'm at a loss for words because it's
that exciting and that world changing
with Bitcoin you can pull out your iPod
or your iPhone or your tablet or
whatever install an app in less than 30
seconds you have the ability to send and
receive money with anyone anywhere in
the world basically for free and you can
be 10 years old and do that or you can
be 100 years old and do that you can be
that in any country
that's Magic
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]